let me ask you okay show hands guys uh
how many
of you your woman tells wonderful
stories
the guy holding this woman and she's
cold okay go ahead
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i told you and he's looking at this
white couple right and she's just like
because she don't look like a villain
and so she's just daddy
but she don't tell a good story she just
she don't what's your name
dave what's your name hi this is truth
when you call dave from another room
dave immediately
he goes
what the what does she want
now
daddy you want to hear what happened to
me today
oh i make my girl tell me the end of a
story first
before i invest any more time into
listening to the rest of it you wanna
hear what happened to me today no what
happened
somebody got shot all right go ahead try
the toy story
[Applause]
starts all wrong you know my friend
diane right
uh
no i don't really i don't you know diane
i don't know diane i i don't now i gotta
tell you
another two hour story so you know we're
right heading
remember ten years ago i made you go to
a party you didn't want to go to
and i introduced you to some people you
didn't care about well diane was one of
them remember
yeah yeah i remember you don't remember
you're just saying you'll remember
so i could tell the story faster well
why don't you tell the story faster
sweetie
who got shot did diane get shot no did
she did she shoot somebody no
well why did you say diana because we
were talking and she don't like guns and
i don't like guns and i
and i think they should make a rocket
ship and shoot all guns
into another oh god nobody if you're
gonna yell at me forget it
oh you made me feel bad
everything's based on how they feel
you can hear when they tell stories you
ever told him man tell a story it'd be
just facts
who what when where why it was me and
bob
we use that safeway then [ __ ] bob said
this then i punched that [ __ ] and i
broke out
that's the store
that's the story women tell stories all
these feelings well first of all you
understand i was on my period and i just
talked to my mother so i was feeling
like i was like ah damn too many
feelings
what the [ __ ] happened to it do it
then the bra burning generation came in
right now you get to sit there and
listen to their stories all the time
oh it's the worst you know what's the
worst is when they're telling you a
story and you want to listen but that's
what they're talking about you can't
even retain it
so i'm supposed to go out to lunch with
jennifer i'm all ready to do that i show
up she's there with susan she knows i
hate susan
i look like [ __ ] susan's been going to
the gym i mean at that point your head
is like a newborn baby you're trying to
try to hold it up you know
you can't even if you're trying to pay
attention you can't then
you just start staring at their mouth
after a while like i can't believe it
keeps coming out this is [ __ ]
unbelievable
he's like around
you start thinking about your own life
right why don't i take nebraska giving
28.
the [ __ ] is wrong with me it's an
awakening and i'll send her a voice go
hey it goes up
right god [ __ ] that was a question
all right now what do you do can't say
yes you can't say no you got to come
with something neutral hey what the [ __ ]
you gonna do what are you gonna do
this is what it is you put one foot in
front of the other and uh
halftime adjustments ah i got nothing
[Music]
the thing that she's usually mad about
is simple she says that i don't listen
to her
when she's talking and i don't
but it's not because i don't love her
blah blah
it's because
i try to listen i really do when she
talks i just stare at her face i'm like
come on
bring the story
but somehow i'm like what the [ __ ] i
can't do it i try
because every story gets divided into 50
stories that all branch out
into these crazy and i'm like holy [ __ ]
i've got add i can't do it on my [ __ ]
please
but i try every time i try because i
love this [ __ ] woman so i try really
hard
to listen to her stories
other people don't even try we go to
parties she starts talking people just
walk away like [ __ ] this that lady's
crazy
who would waste time listening to that
crap me
she can't help it i really feel bad for
cause the thing is that every word of
the story gets her so excited that she
wants to [ __ ] run with it and
she can't [ __ ] just break through and
get to the end or even the beginning
this is my wife telling a story
she's like guess what happened to my mom
today i was done you remember i told you
my mom how she when she was in college
not when she went to michigan when she
transferred
remember because that guy got weird and
she had to leave because he was not the
iranian guy that was a different story
that guy actually i think he was persian
i heard that persia actually split what
the [ __ ] are you talking
about jesus
christ
pick a thing have some consideration for
the [ __ ] listener
i don't do that here's me telling a
story i bought a tomato and i ate it and
it was good
that's a story anyone can follow it's
about a tomato the whole time